good afternoon this is a great day
because today we have officially
launched and dedicated the Jackson
Institute for Global Affairs at Yale and
we've had for a number of alumni a day
full of panels discussing global affairs
all in celebration of the magnificent
gift of John and Susan Jackson who are
here with us in the front row this
afternoon
the Jackson Institute will be a locus
housing our undergraduate international
Studies major
soon to be reformulated as a global
affairs major and our international
relations graduate program and as the
convener for discussion of contemporary
global affairs both within this campus
and around the world we're very excited
about the prospects for this
extraordinary institution we we have
been able to bring to Yale in the first
year a number of extraordinary
practitioners of of diplomacy and
economic policy who are teaching this
course is this year taursus that seemed
to have astonishingly a great interest
among students of course offered by
Steven Roach on the Chinese economy
seems to about 200 students taking it
the gateway course offered by the
director of the new Institute Jim
Levinson also as a comparable enrollment
we're told that approximately half of
Yale undergraduates signed up for
admission into general McChrystal's
seminar a only a small number we're let
in but in any event we are we're very
excited about what this does to enliven
discussion in the Yale community by
bringing people to Yale who are both
serious thinkers but who have practical
experience and so that's a good segue to
a serious thinker with practical
experience one of the great privileges
of my job is is I get to work with the
Yale corporation which I wouldn't say
has a monopoly on the most talented an
interesting graduates of Yale but it
certainly has a remarkable share of such
people
and for the past several years it's been
just a great pleasure for me to be able
to work on a regular basis with Fareed
Zakaria who is truly one of our most
distinguished graduates Bri graduated
from Yale College in 1986 he went on to
Harvard and got a PhD in government then
at a precocious age of 28 became the
editor of foreign affairs magazine had
held that job for about a decade that
eight years and then he moved on to
Newsweek where he became the editor of
Newsweek international and a weekly
columnist and then after years of giving
his own opinion he he he was signed on
with CNN in the context in which many of
you are familiar with him to become
perhaps the best informed most
articulate and most incisive television
interviewer in the area of of national
and international affairs in his Fareed
Zakaria GPS show which airs on Sunday
nights right and with the time slot you
doing okay yeah
it's so we're gonna turn the tables on
for read today and make him be be the
person who is asked the questions I'm
gonna see if I can do I used to say my
Charlie Rose Imitation but now I'm going
to say my Fareed Zakaria imitation and
asking and asking him the questions okay
so for me maybe we should tour the
horizon a bit in the international
domain since your this has been a great
interest of yours for a couple of
decades and and why don't we start with
Iraq this is you you've supported the
initial invasion in Iraq in 2003 became
somewhat disenchanted initially thought
the surge was a bad idea as a true
empiricist an open-minded person changed
her mind afterward and now the troops
have left
how would you size it up now in in
historic perspective how do you think
history will read the Iraq intervention
from now how will it seem well you know
when when when Kissinger made the
opening to China in his one of his
initial conversations with Chou Enlai
the Chinese premier he said to him I
don't know what they were why they were
talking about this but he said to him
what do you think of the French
Revolution and Chou Enlai looked at him
and said it's really too early to tell
don't you think this is the 1973 so I I
do think it's very difficult to look
back and ask yourself honestly how this
will play itself out just give you one
example you've all lived through the
impeachment of Bill Clinton the general
you remember this was the absolute pivot
that the United States was going through
the passions were so deep it now really
feels like a rather bizarre period in in
American history and we look back after
all the assorted scandals that said we
almost impeached a president over that
remember the undergraduates were only
but I think that getting rid of Saddam
Hussein has been a positive thing both
in terms of national security and in
terms of morality I mean I think people
come to sometimes forget this is not a
garden-variety dictatorship this was one
of the worst regimes in the world it had
you know killed on a conservative
estimate something close to a million
two million people depending on whether
you add in the numbers from the
iran-iraq war
so really awful regime that had placed
the United States in this unwinnable
position where it had this brutal cruel
sanctions regime that was killing 50,000
Iraqi children a year that required a
presence in Saudi Arabia which by the
way was the reason Osama bin Laden what
you know issued his original fatwa
against the United States people now
forget the plight of the Palestinian
people was number three on his list the
most important reason why Osama bin
Laden launched his jihad was that we
were occupying Saudi Arabia which we
were doing in order to contain Saddam
Hussein so I do think there are
enormous benefits that have come from it
Iraq is in fact an open and free society
the Kurdish areas are remarkably free
increasingly that's true in the Shia
areas but I think you'd have to be
honest and say the costs do not the
costs outweigh the benefits at this
point the enormous costs of the war in
terms of the lives of Americans the
lives of Iraqis the the way in which had
shattered Iraq it's very difficult to
make the case right now that the
benefits outweigh the costs maybe in the
long arc of history that will change but
right now I think you know if anyone had
to do it over again and they would still
say they would invade Iraq I would
suggest that they are not being either
they're not being honest
or they are not true embarrasses you
know with no weapons of mass destruction
with it costing a trillion dollars with
the enormous chaos that has put a rock
into having said that I do think we
should be trying to work toward a
reasonable successful outcome look when
when Eisenhower concluded the Korean War
he made a decision to leave 50,000
troops in Korea because he thought the
war has ended in this very indecisive
manner but we could stabilize South
Korea and that could yield something
positive and the reality was it took 30
years South Korea was a complete mess a
very tough brutal dictatorship until in
the 1980s but what emerged as a result
was a peaceful stable increasingly
democratic country in a crucial part of
the world which also was hospitable to
the west to America to American
interests it's not inconceivable that
were weeded in some way get Iraq right
with much lower numbers of troops
you could have an outcome that
ultimately twenty or thirty years from
now people will say you know what Iraq
is a stable increasingly democratic
society in a sea of dictatorships in the
Arab world that is a model for other
Arab countries and at that point I don't
know if it still was worth it but it
you can make the case that the United
States has done something that has been
good for the world good for the Middle
East and good for its own interests is
it stable enough now to survive our
reduced commitment or could it could it
be disrupted by terrorists or
opposition's my own gut is that it is
stable enough an aide to General
Petraeus said to me at some point the
the worst parts of the violence when I
was in Iraq he said the this this Iraqi
civil war will end once the Sunnis
realized that they have lost and the
Shia realized that they have won meaning
at some point the shear will realize
their governing the country you know
they don't need to be so vengeful and
wrathful and at some point the Sunnis
will realize no matter how many
terrorist attacks they have at the end
of the day they are 28 18 percent of the
country and they won't they will never
get back the cockpit of power that they
had I think that's basically happened so
you have spoilers and you have you know
occasional militia groups on both sides
well you don't have right now which
would really bring enormous stability is
a national leader who is willing to
broaden the the political compact
basically you have a lot of very
hardline shear rulers who feel as though
we've been waiting for this chance for
400 years and goddamnit it's our turn
now and we're gonna squeeze them as hard
as they squeezed us it's unfortunate if
you had a kind of I don't know
Washington like figure that would change
the dynamic dramatically I think and and
then you would you know it just shows
you how these crucial moments leadership
actually is very important and Iraq is
not blessed with particularly good
leadership at this point moving eastward
to Afghanistan I think there was much
wider consensus upon our initial entry
into Afghanistan on the wake of the
terrorist attacks in September 11th 2001
but but we seem to be stuck in a morass
there it's a country with a history of
no outside victors for many centuries I
mean what are we doing right what are we
doing wrong
what what do you see is the prognosis
for Afghanistan my own view is that we
should have done something much closer
to Vice President Biden's idea which was
the central problem in Afghanistan that
that implicates the United States is in
terms of national security is that Al
Qaeda is still active there and in
Pakistan and that if you were to simply
withdraw from Afghanistan it is possible
to imagine a renewed heightened al Qaeda
presence camps operating again planning
for terrorist activities again and in
that circumstance you know you will have
left behind a festering problem that
will what they will come back I believe
you could have dealt you could deal with
that with a combination of some ground
presence in Afghanistan it's not true
that you can just go away because you
need intelligence you need to be a
player on the ground for people to trust
you enough to just give you intelligence
so you would need 3040 thousand troops I
think we right now have 150,000 troops
and are trying to effectively determine
the political outcome of Afghanistan it
strikes me as a holding pattern that is
to say we will be able to do it for a
while but we'll be treading water
because the minute we leave you know
it's that moment you that you realize
you can you can make this work as long
as you have 150,000 troops there but is
there a self-sustaining ability to
create an independent Afghan security
force absent again a political deal
absent political legitimacy for the
government it's tough and these things
take a long time so my own gut would
have been try to move to something that
looks more like counterterrorism special
operations it would still be messy you
still you lose loose people in the fight
but most importantly what you'd be
giving up just to be clear there will be
parts of Afghanistan you would be ceding
to bad actors in the short run you never
know how these things work out because
the Afghans also will have a fight it's
not as though the Taliban can easily
sweep in to power in any of these places
there are other forces there are there
is spirited resistance but we'd have to
be willing to countenance all that I
think Obama has ended up with
a fairly smart practical
middle-of-the-road compromise which is
this he realized that that option the
Biden option was no longer available to
him because the military general
McChrystal and Petraeus essentially
boxed him in they leaked the requests
that they were making and for a
Democratic president somebody perceived
as a Liberal Democratic president to
overturn the military overrule the
military on a core issue of national
security was just not going to be viable
so he couldn't you know he couldn't turn
them down flat who have just politically
not would not been possible the
Republicans would have made enormous hay
with it
so what he said to them is ok I'll give
you you know first of all well you know
let me be clear because there was a
range of options you're gonna get the
low end of your range not the high end
and secondly I give you 18 months
stabilize the country as much as you can
but in 18 months we're gonna draw down
to this smaller profile I think that's
reasonable people now say well we should
just get the hell out of that well even
if you did want to get the hell out of
there how fast can you would draw
150,000 troops cuz remember those 50,000
NATO forces you know it would take you
six months nine months in nine months
you're gonna begin a process of
withdrawal anyway so I think it's a
fairly sensible policy which gives the
military some time to train the Afghan
army to you know take effect break the
momentum of the Taliban but ultimately I
believe that the goal is for us to have
a much smaller presence in Afghanistan
and I think the broader goal if you look
at Iraq where he's gone down from a
hundred to 50 if you look at Afghanistan
where over three years it's pretty clear
we're going to come down I believe that
what you're seeing in a is an Obama
world view which is to rebalance
American foreign policy away from these
crisis centers where we are stuck trying
to adjudicate the disputes between the
Sunnis and Shias which is essentially a
dispute that has gone on since the 15th
century where we are trying to dig in
and negotiate the disputes between the
the Pashtun and the non question in
Afghanistan which is gone
for at least the 15th century Britain
was doing exactly this a hundred years
ago and to move us out of that role and
to spend more time and energy on what is
happening in China what is happening in
India engaging more with Brazil so in a
sense I believe it is an attempt to
rebalance away from the past of American
foreign policy to the future and I think
he's doing it about us as sensibly as
it's possible given political
constraints so are you saying that
nation-building in these areas should
should should be scrapped as a as a
political objective once we're out of
these two countries I think we should we
should encourage it I think we should
try to do what we can but the idea that
we could assume responsibility in the
way that we did with Japan and Germany
it's just a bridge too far it's enormous
ly expensive its enormous ly
time-consuming it saps the the the time
energy of the country and it's not clear
that there is a big enough security
interest that you know that you can
justify it look this director of the CIA
claims that there are 400 members of
al-qaeda left in Afghanistan by some
estimates he believes there may be only
200 and then there are another 400 in
Pakistan which is where they're really
operating out of at this point you have
to ask yourself so if you're talking
about something like three or four
hundred five hundred people do you need
a hundred and fifty thousand people at 1
billion dollars per soldier per year
which is what it costs you know I mean
that's a lot of money and that's a lot
of our time energy and attention I
guarantee you that the president's
foreign policy time is right now 80 80 %
Iraq and Afghanistan because when you
have American you know boys and girls
out on there and risking their lives of
course that becomes the dominant concern
and how much time are you thinking about
the strategic relationship with China
which is going to be the pivotal
relationship how much you're thinking
about how you build an alliance with
India without pissing off the Chinese
which is absolutely crucial how much are
you thinking about what to do about the
balance between your relations with
Brazil which are very important and your
relations with Mexico
and how you maintain the balance which
is there's an interesting rivalry
beginning in Latin America you know he's
spending very little time on that so
he's we've got to get out of the eighth
century makes a lot of sense so before I
move on to exactly those issues of China
India Brazil Mexico let's just are you
are you if you if you are you also
saying that that counterterrorism should
no longer be as it was for the past
decade the principal objective of u.s.
foreign policy it's it's a very good
question Rick I think the way I would
put it is counterterrorism should
continue to be a dominant concern of the
American national security establishment
I strongly believe that al Qaeda is a
much weaker force than it wasn't on 9/11
and i think this is for a combination of
two reasons one we've gone after them
we've chased them around the mountains
of afghanistan we've bombed them in
pakistan we track their money we follow
these people around we don't let them go
into countries this is all working the
second part is they have been
spectacularly foolish and what they have
done they have overreached they've
killed locals in all these countries
from saudi arabia to egypt to morocco
and that pisses locals off guess what
it's it's it's fun it's fine to give
tacit support for you know some distant
group that seems to be killing Americans
and soldiers and Westerners and it all
sounds great and you can seem
fashionable and talk about the
Palestinian cause when they start
killing Saudis and I was in Saudi Arabia
a week after the attack all of a sudden
they said my god these are radicals
these are horrible people you know
they're they're they're bigots they're
extremists we've got to do something
about them and so those two things are
very crucial to Al Qaeda's weakness we
should keep the pressure on but as an
intellectual construct I think that I
think that there's something we have we
have over done this this kind of clash
of civilizations this war on terror I've
just been reading Tony Blair's memoirs I
keep mentioning people who have a Yale
Association its McChrystal Tony Blair
that's part of your your imperial reach
that you've kind of been able to you
know I'm trying to think of somebody who
doesn't have a yogic
and you know absolutely brilliant
politician but clearly 9/11 had this
effect of transforming his worldview
where you know it's all poor thing
becomes part of this great struggle and
to me that my favorite example of that
is so he in a throwaway line about
Chechnya about talking to Putin about
Chechnya he says and I understand that
at core they have a problem of a violent
vicious secessionist movement that is at
chorus one of his Islamic extremism now
you know where to begin I mean the
Chechens were brutally incorporated into
the Russian Empire in 1865 I think after
45 years of violent struggle the Russia
you know they've been trying to secede
ever since on purely nationalist grounds
the Russians treated them brutally
Stalin deported the entire population of
Chechnya to Central Asia they then tried
but try been trying in those last ten
years the Russian army has killed
100,000 civilians in Chechnya and yes
now they have a bit of a problem with
Islamic extremism but you know it to
talk about it in those terms is to miss
something and I fear is that when we
just look at the world through this war
on Islamic extremism we're missing a lot
of the the nuance well there okay so
let's take your assumption is correct
that al Qaeda is much diminished and the
actual terrorist involvement is reduced
but but Tony Blair would argue there's
still a long-term threat because of
religious fundamentalism actually on all
sides I mean in Israel in in the Muslim
world in US domestic politics from
fundamentalist Christians that that all
these that there's a role in diplomacy
for somehow getting these groups to be
brought into the more into the
mainstream do you think that's should be
a serious concern oh I think it should
be I think it should be a concern I
think let's be stop being politically
correct there is no great danger of
terrorism coming out of fundamentalist
Christians as Jews the real problem is
Islamic extremism but I do think there
there is a tendency to and you see this
again in Blair's mom was to conflate
everything you know so that there is a
great problem of the rise of Islamic
fundamentalism I mean the India I grew
up in you in in Bombay you would not see
a lot of women wearing veils you see
many more now if you go the first time I
went to Cairo in 1974 you would have to
search to find a woman bearing a whale
today it's the opposite you'd have to
search to find a woman not wearing a
veil but that is not the same as
terrorism there is a broader rise of
religiosity in this in these societies
probably a backlash against
globalization and modernity but the veil
is not the suicide belt and it's very
important we make that distinction so
every time we see this and the you know
and they they seem so other and they're
wearing these black robes and you're
sure that they're all you know terribly
backward I don't know I think again we
should worry about what is worth
worrying about which is people who are
trying to kill us and to the extent that
women in Islamic societies want to cover
their hair you know I mean I I think it
in my own view it is not a step forward
for women's liberation but you know that
will work itself out in those those
societies here here so before we leave
this part of the world just maybe a few
words about Iran which you know you've
written about that and about how you
don't think it would be very fruitful to
try to undermine the current regime
elaborate a little bit on what you think
about our role toward Iran for sure I
think it's very important to go back to
first principles with Iran and first
remind ourselves this is a country that
is you know a middling regional power
Iran's GDP is about a hundred and eighty
two billion dollars to give you some
perspective the Pentagon's budget is
seven hundred billion dollars so we
spend militarily three times three and a
half times their entire annual GDP Iran
has not invaded a foreign country in 150
years it has by and large behaved in a
perfectly rational manner that does not
mean a one that is to our liking I mean
by that a calculating manner they have
opportunistically advanced the interest
when they could and they have not the
central issue that people worry about
and I understand the worry is Iran's
attitude towards Israel I would argue
that if you look at what's going on it
is Iran is making a bid for leadership
in the Middle East and for a portion
sheer country to make a bid for
leadership in the Middle East the only
way they can credibly do that is to
appropriate the main cause of the Arab
world which is the Palestinian cause and
so they have achieved something
remarkable which is you go to Cairo and
you will find on the streets of Cairo
photographs of Ahmadinejad a portion as
the great hero of the Sunni masses now
why is he doing this because he is
trying to prevent the Egyptian
government from mounting a serious
anti-iranian containment policy it you
notice the Egyptian government does not
denounce Iran much publicly they hate
them privately they are constantly
urging the United States to attack Iran
but they will not say that publicly
because on their street people say wait
a minute
Ahmadinejad is the great hero of the
Palestinian cause you see the same
dynamic by the way now with Turkey it is
fascinating to watch what's happening in
the Middle East which is that there are
two countries making a bid for
leadership of the Arab world neither of
which happened to be Arab it is Iran
Turkey and the Turks also discovered
exactly the same thing which is we need
to have street cred and to have street
cred means to take on the Palestinian
cause and so the the Turkish president
is doing it I deplore it because it's a
kind of cheap populism but it does not
mean that they want to you know they
want a bomb Israel Israel has 250
nuclear weapons it has a second strike
survivable capacity the people running
Iran are busily ferreting away money and
Dubai bank accounts so that their
children and grandchildren can have
trust funds these are not people who are
about to create the end of their days
you know I mean this is a very
calculating corrupt regime so for all
those reasons I think it can be
contained it can be deterred look people
forget Mao was totally bonkers I mean
people would would routinely talk about
ending half the world because the other
half at least would be communist
that out of the ruins of a world war
would come communism and you know we
didn't we didn't think that meant that
he couldn't be convertible some people
did think that he couldn't be contained
but hip history is proving them wrong
and Stalin was containable and the
Pakistanis are containable I mean all
these countries have nuclear weapons and
at the end of the day we we understand
it's a difficult dilemma but you can
determine contain them there is
something bizarre about the view that
the Iranians alone have this you know
kind of genetic condition which will
make them commit suicide mass suicide we
got a little worried by Khrushchev
anything about it yeah sacrificing Cuban
lives more you know before your time the
well whoa okay so finally in this region
is is is this Hillary's chance to really
make a mark with it with Israel
Palestine discussions might might this
be the great capstone for her career to
actually negotiate something there well
you know nobody has ever lost money
betting against the Middle East peace
process so I think that if you have if
you are betting you know that it's
pretty clear what you should do in terms
of the odds if it happens I'll say this
I don't think it will be Hillary Clinton
who will make it happen
another Yale graduate I think that
ultimately this depends on Israel Israel
is the power on the ground Israel has
the land and the hopeful sign is there
are two hopeful signs one Bibi Netanyahu
seems to have decided that you know what
maybe I can do a Nixon goes to China
maybe this time there is this
possibility and he's speaking in a
different way over the last few weeks
than he is before so something there has
changed and that's very hopeful and the
second is Israel is doing so damn well
you know I mean Israel if you look at
the Israeli economy it's it's it is on
steroids it is you know this has become
there's this book book out called
startup nation the Israel has more
listed Nasdaq companies than than any
country other than the United States it
is I mean it's extraordinary I I have a
theory about this by the way
which is you know how Russia people
thought was going to be a very promising
economy and has turned out to be
terrible and Israel was this kind of
socialist economy and it's turned out to
grow like gangbusters well about a
million I have Russian Jameson from
Russia to Israel and basically all the
smart people in Russia went to Israel
and started businesses there some just
lost some of them bought oil and mineral
deposits in Stata the rest went to
Israel that's right exactly exactly
those who could became oligarchs in
Russia other one-and-a-half million went
to Israel but it's actually true if you
look at the startup the Silicon Valley
phenomenon it's all Russian immigrants
and they're all technically trained they
have some engineering background so if
there's hope it's that now the downside
is and actually this is related the
Russian emigre is also pretty tough
characters they are not particularly
accommodating they have you know they
have a kind of Soviet style of dealing
with politics and you see that in the
Foreign Minister Avigdor Lieberman who
is talking about population transfers
which is you know a truly remarkable
thing to hear an Israeli Foreign
Minister talking about the forcible
expulsion of people without their you
know without their permission III think
I'm right in saying the last time that
has happened in a significant way was
with Germany and in Czechoslovakia and
the 1930s that is the the forced
expulsion of the you know during the
annexation of the Sudetenland was the
was the only time I can remember you
draw borders around people and tell them
you know kind of run around so it's it's
it's very sad that you're hearing that
come out of Israel
well it wasn't forced I suppose during
the partition and Indian Pakistan it
wasn't forced in many cases where people
have been told to leave but yeah but but
for for intra modern democracy to be
saying you know we're gonna we're going
to disenfranchise tens if not hundreds
of thousands of people don't you think
this will ultimately leave Israel to
some accommodation I mean they're gonna
have
to deal with the fact their population
is going to be a majority non-jewish
population over a couple of decades or
so my gut is yes my gut is that
ultimately Israel is it ultimately
Israel is a democracy and it cannot
sustain its key Democratic character
with three million people ruled against
their wishes in these you know
particularly in Gaza a Gaza fella
appalling conditions and I think that if
the Palestinians had always played on
the if the Palestinian strategy had been
to shame the Israelis I believe there
would be a Palestinian state because the
the reality is it is a democracy and
ultimately I don't think they can live
with this but it may take a while okay
well let's talk about China and in
and/or India what maybe China first this
you've you've written in your most
recent book most American world that
America is going to have to learn how to
share power gracefully an appropriate
way that it can still be a leader but it
won't be the exclusive hegemon of global
affairs China looked set until actually
the last year or so as though they were
embarked on a course of what they called
the peaceful rise and the last year they
seem to have gotten a bit more
belligerent at least both economically
and militarily what's going on do you
agree with that characterization and I
think they're two things going on the
first is they have had a spectacular
crisis you know if there's one country
that has come out of this crisis renewed
reinvigorated it is China not just
because they grew at 9% last year and
they'll probably grow even faster this
year but if they look at it and I'm this
you know this is how the Chinese look at
these things because they're very
thoughtful and calculating about it they
look at the last 10 years and they ask
themselves how did we handle you know
our our economy and how did the United
States the leading country in the world
that they always looked up to handle it
so that the Chinese over the last 10
years did three things when the country
was growing at what they considered an
excessively fast pace they wrote raised
interest rates to take down some of the
growth to take down some of the froth
they tightened credit in the two years
before the economic crisis they
tightened credit 13 times and they built
up a budget surplus because they figured
when the wheel turns will need
ammunition so let's have some you know
let's have some surplus in the bank and
when the wheel did turn as you know the
lorda interest rates they eased up on
consumer credit and they spent a lot of
money there there is stimulus is ten
times larger than ours as a percentage
of GDP correct said the largest fiscal
stimulus as a percentage of GDP that I
can omit certainly since World War two
if you call that a fiscal stimulus so
they look at that and then think what
did the Americans do at that same period
well when we were growing fast we
lowered interest rates to Goose the
economy to get a little more juice out
of it we eased up one credit in every
form but particularly in housing credit
where you know the goal of the Bush
administration was to add two three four
million more houses which plainly meant
you were telling Fannie Mae and Freddie
Mac give people houses that they can't
afford and finally we destroyed the
federal budget if you think about
between the Bush tax cuts the
prescription drugs for the elderly and
the two wars you created and without any
taxes to pay for any of it you created a
five percent structural deficit in the
American budget which meant that when
you got the crisis you you know and care
tax revenues collapse you're now at ten
percent so the Chinese look at this and
say who should be lecturing whom about
the world you know who should be you
know who should be paid political risk
to be invested in we should be paying
political risk to invest in America not
not the other way around and there is
that arrogance creeping into China
justifiably so I was talking to a
Chinese official senior official who
said to me you know Hank Paulson used to
come here and he both of his old jobs
when he was head of Goldman Sachs and
his Secretary of Treasury and he keep
lecturing us on how the Chinese needed
to learn from the Americans about
restructuring their foreign
industry and he paused and said I don't
think we'll be getting any of those
lectures anytime and I think that that's
you know that's how they now view the
world so it is different and you know
it's it's you I I hesitate even to call
it arrogance because it is a confidence
based on a fair reading of the facts I'd
have to say I agree with that what what
about there what about the military
moves and the sort of claims on the
South China Sea and the stronger the
stronger attempt to show that that kind
of strength as well as economics but
there what you're seeing is something
very interesting which is the Chinese
are trying to figure out what is our
national security what is our national
they all know if you talk to Chinese
leaders they'll all say well we need a
larger role in the world
we need to seat at the table but they
don't quite know what that means you
know what what is their position on
Iranian nuclear weapons what is I mean
they have they have pro forma positions
but they do not have a thought through
vision of what their broader interests
are what they do have is a fairly clear
sense of what their narrower interests
are which is Chinese foreign policy
basically is about two things right now
it's about securing natural resources
that they need and Taiwan if you look at
their votes on at the UN those are the
only two things that they see have any
consistent you know application on
everything else
they basically abstain or they give the
Americans what they want or they don't
you know the only things they care about
passionately are those things and on the
first which is the natural resources
they are very clearly expanding their
their sphere and if you look at the way
in which they are building then maybe it
is to secure those trade routes if you
look at where they are building ports
either leasing or building them it is a
chain of ports around India basically
which is not so much a you know kind of
aggressive move toward India it is an
attempt to create an unbreakable link to
the Africa and the Persian Gulf they are
trying to create routes for their you
know for their raw materials coming out
of Africa and for their energy supplies
at this point you know the south side of
China sees a is going to
be a place where I would guess I'm
guessing at this point but half of world
trade is probably passing through now
and probably two-thirds of world trade
will pass through in the next 20 25
years so who secures that becomes as
important as the Atlantic used to be you
know in the previous two or three
hundred years and the Chinese are very
determined to make sure that they are
the principle player there and that
bumps up against our interest you know
in the United States has always said
that we believe in a balance of power in
Asia we don't really mean that we
believe in a massive imbalance of power
in our face exactly and the Chinese
actually trying to change that so he
were Obama would you let him have the
South fantasy I think this is going to
be the great challenge of Obama's
foreign policy and the next president
after that which is how to accommodate
China enough that you don't give them a
sense that they are being locked out of
the international system but at the same
time draw some lines so that there is
also a deterrent funk funk ssin my own
sense is that what they are asking for
what right now in the in these actions
is not objectionable that it first of
all you can't actually stop them the Sri
Lankan government is signing you know
it's made doing the deal with them to
build a port the Pakistani government is
doing a deal with them to do a port how
do you you can't really stop that but
also we shouldn't really stop that it is
understandable that they want secure
energy and raw material supplies I think
that what we should be trying to do is
two things one make clear that you know
we would regard the use of force to
resolve the Taiwan issue to resolve any
border dispute either in the South China
Seas and crucially in India on the on
the Indo Chinese border as unacceptable
but also involve them in a greater sense
of kind of solving some of these
problems and the great mismatch right
now in the world is that you have the
United States and some Western countries
that have this kind of collective order
conception of the world where we want
other countries to join in to create
common goods to solve common problems
whether it's nuclear nuclear
proliferation whether it's climate
change and you have the Chinese and
honestly the Indians and Brazilians as
well who are not in that kind of post
national collective security mentality
they're very much modern countries on
the rise
thinking about things in national
interest terms not international
interest terms and you know they don't
see anything wrong with the assertion of
their nash their parochial national
interests and that's as true by the way
for brazil as it is for china I mean the
Brazilians if you look at the way in
which they've been dealing with the
Middle East where they are trying to to
get a kind of privileged position by
signing deals with Ahmadinejad and such
this is all an attempt to create a kind
of Brazilian national you know foreign
policy we're gonna have to get over that
because the truth of the matter is you
do need these larger countries thinking
in broader terms our best bet is
honestly with the with the Chinese
because the Chinese do get this you know
I mean I think Tom Friedman wrote in his
column today the nice thing I were going
to China is you know you don't have to
have a big debate about climate change
because these guys are all engineers you
know they understand science and
similarly you know they understand the
the value of having some degree of
collective problem solving but it bumps
up but when it bumps up against the
Chinese national interest
they are very jealous of their
sovereignty they're very very and very
zealous in guarding that sovereignty in
India your home country they survived
the crisis perhaps second best of all
yeah the Indians still survived the
crisis second best of all I think that's
fairly saying also by the way very good
very good management of their economic
policy one of the people who were who
managed India's economic policy Rakesh
Moniz in the second row so he's probably
one of those people gloating inside
while well you know courteously
receiving American visitors would
lecture him on financial reform and but
and by the way the other the other
reason both China and India did very
well is they both have very you know you
could see this and I should ask you this
but my sense was after a couple of way
or months of the crisis when you know
there was no money anywhere at all fled
the Indians and Chinese sort of shake
themselves off and say wait a minute we
don't have any subprime problems we
don't have any overextended consumers
why are we declining and suddenly you
see that all these markets start going
back up the economy so the confidence
comes back to the system because
fundamentally they were healthy the more
it came back but China did experience a
very dramatic drop in its exports
because of the dry markets abroad so
they had they used a very effective
fiscal stimulus - what - India didn't
need to because it was less reliant on
exports more reliant on domestic
consumption but I think that
fundamentally the Indians are natural
allies of the United States because the
single the most important geopolitical
fact in the world right now is the rise
of China and in terms of that
geopolitical fact the Indians and the
United States on the same side that is
to say they both hope it happens
peacefully they welcome it because it
adds to a kind of greater global
prosperity but they are wary and want to
be sure that there is some hedging
strategy that is possible now that said
the problem you'll find in India in my
opinion is a very difficult country to
deal with very prickly lots of
post-colonial issues they're still a
unreconstructed left in India that
believes it is absolute heresy for the
you know for the President of the United
States to be given a red-carpet
reception in India is not large and I
think that by and large the Indian
certainly the civilian community that is
the non-governmental community is very
pro-american and engaged in fact if you
saw there have been opinion polls you
know these pew surveys and the Indians
have consistently been the number the
number one or number two most
pro-american country in the world that
is the the average person but that's not
you know there is a old bureaucracy that
Rakesh mone used to battle with when he
was in government that is still very
tough you know it's very tough to to do
deals with and it's as an old there's a
real left in India that is there's still
a real communist party that believes it
is the original heir to Maoism and think
you know and this is not a joke I mean
you know you you keep wishing they would
actually go and see what the Maoists are
doing in China because you know that's
so it's going to be not as seamless a
alliance or relationship as one might
imagine so but then the less India is
likely to be a friend
and China is increasingly problematic
and difficult to manage the bilateral
relationship but has to be a partner but
it becomes a rival you end up in a very
different world and I think you really
don't want that yeah agreed
so how will that play out because right
now Congress oh there's a lot of popular
sentiment in the United States against
China even even some slippage in the
administration on questions like the
exchange rate yeah in terms of wanting
to be confrontational now instead of I
mean I realized there's an election
coming in three months so my test I'll
turn the question around just start us
off with the exchange rate what should
we think about the exchange rate issue
Paul Krugman writes this is this is
simple they are subsidizing their their
manufacturers at the curb and and the
American worker is paying the price and
lovers should do something and he's he's
a very tough even tariff like
retaliation what do you reckon ahh
--mess would say if they're subsidizing
consumption goods that we get send them
a thank-you note
so those are the regardless and is there
any lasting damage done oh you're too
good
is there any lasting damage done to the
US economy by having China have an
artificially an artificial exchange rate
probably not considerable damage by my
view you know if China if China raised
the state you know revalued you know
American it's not going to dramatically
increase American exports to China and
we're and we're and we're still gonna be
because of our very very low savings
rate a massive net importer so so you
know the way to way to get more
employment in this country is domestic
stimulus there I agree with Paul Krugman
at least halfway
we mean direct job creation and but we
also need to what will never happen
politically but what would be the right
thing economically is job creation now
coupled with credible moves to race the
fiscal deficit in years three to five
like raising the Social Security
retirement age like introducing you know
I you know God forbid higher tax rates
or a value-added tax or some other means
of addressing the structural deficit so
and I'm not really turning the tables
here so I'm gonna I'm gonna posit a
statement and then see what do you agree
one of the things in this in this
regatta you've got somebody this this
smart out one of the things that is
taking place in the right now that I
feel that Americans aren't sufficiently
aware of is the increasingly competitive
global landscape so that if you look at
what are corporate taxes it is now you
know it was twenty years ago the lowest
in the industrialized world it's now the
second-highest if you look at our
regulatory environment you know there
are or alternatives and options whether
they are London Geneva Hongkong
Singapore Shanghai perhaps Indian you
know in the next phase Mumbai it's
certainly Australia Canada and that is a
world that hasn't existed before that
there are just so many different options
to and I don't get the sense that we as
a society are sufficiently attuned to
that reality and are trying to ask
ourselves how do we place ourselves in a
position where we are competitive well
lowering corporate tax rates would not
be politically popular particularly with
Democrats but in truth were it coupled
with other moves that raised that that
raise federal revenues it would actually
be a smart mix because we are not we we
do lose location decisions because of
our high corporate tax rates and I look
at you know the the biggest the biggest
IPO out there right now has been leered
the announcement of Petrobras the
Brazil's petroleum company and Steve
Roach can probably speak to this better
than I can
who got the which investment bank God
you know God the contract a Chinese bank
I mean this will I can tell you there
must have been people there must have
been hundreds of people at Goldman Sachs
and Morgan Stanley who worked for weeks
trying to get this deal and it you know
and this is a very tough thing to
execute this is not easy stuff a largest
private equity deal in the last three
months was a Brazilian private equity
group buying Burger King you know it
really is a new world where it's you
know we used to think that we in the
west where we have the we have the the
capital and we have the know-how but now
they have the capital and they already
know how was and you know wasn't your
subtitle the rise of the rest yeah and
didn't you then didn't you say we should
welcome this and embrace it oh no yeah
but but we'll have to adapt to it and I
feel that there is a real I just don't
get the feeling that people you know
understand that it's a it's a very
different landscape even it was ten
years ago you know I mean I see come I
think that there is going to be a major
bank that's going to move to Singapore
in the next 15 years as its headquarters
and that's going to be a kind of shock
to the system that you can actually
imagine that happen mm-hmm I think
that's right so what would you how would
you go about if you if you could do this
addressing the the various you know
recovery from the economic crisis from
the standpoint United States you know I
mean I agree with you probably some
fiscal stimulus is necessary in the
short term but my problem with that is
at the end of the day what you're hoping
to do is provide a bridge to get people
spending again seventy percent of the
American economy is consumption so the
government can spend first only so long
before at some point private sector
spending has it particularly people have
to start spending because company is
only going to spend when they see demand
and that demand is only going to be
created when the consumer starts
spending again and I think there's
something again here that's check that
is dramatically changed we've come off a
25-year binge an expansion of credit the
consumers shell-shocked the savings rate
which was you know everybody said
Americans don't say it's back up to six
percent who knows what it could go even
higher in my opinion it would be a very
rational
for people to allow it to go a little
bit higher you know just to who knows
what the world is gonna be like you've
rebuild your balance sheet and in that
context I don't know that you know you
can't just keep spending forever and so
at some point you have to transition to
a set of strategies that really reset
the economy get you frankly less reliant
on consumer spending more reliant on
investment and exports and what does
that mean to you know to my mind is all
the hard stuff
you know we've fudged all the hard stuff
for the last 30 years our secondary
school system has collapsed we pretended
that was not a problem science and
Technical Education has collapsed in
this country we pretended that wasn't a
problem we've come up with a whole bunch
of cheap short-term solutions to them
like you know we don't produce any
scientists or engineers anymore don't
worry we'll just skim the world's best
will just take you know the best
immigrants from the world they get
trained in their in their countries and
they can come here actually we've been
doing that since the 1930s right
absolutely Hitler began it was a
greatest gift Hitler ever ever made to
the you know the United States but you
know at some point you can't avoid the
reality that your secondary school
system has collapsed and that your
science and technical education has
collapsed and that you know you're you
you have created this massively this
completely inflated housing sector
because if you look at what we do in a
housing right we we have the mortgage
deduction for interest which is a 100
billion dollar subsidy or you you have
non-recourse loans which is absurd well
you know it's the one area you can just
walk away from your loan and it's the
bank's problem you have Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac pumping money and and then
we're surprised that you get a housing
crisis and you know we've been rich
enough and we've been like sitting on
Mount Olympus it didn't matter what we
did we could screw up because the rest
of the world was so far behind but
they're not so far behind and that's
that's what I feel we just it's stuff we
understand you know we've got to start
living within our means and educating
properly and teaching our kids there are
you know the simple things like you know
how do you make stuff to the rest of the
world wants but it's all very hard
very painful and nobody gets elected
saying that so the debate right now is
between fiscal stimulus and tax cuts
which by the way is of another form of
fiscal stimulus the Republicans don't
realize when they say tax cut thing
they're also been Keynesian it's just
another kind of Keynesianism
but it's not a long-term solution to the
problem yeah well let me just I want to
get back to education but let me just
take up that last point it's not true
it's not true in a deep recession where
there's too much leverage that a tax cut
and IA and direct spending to employ
people is fiscally equivalent it's not
there's no stimulus saved because if you
give people a tax cut they'll save it in
the market and the multiplier effect
from federal stimulus depends on the
marginal propensity to consume agree and
and and so if you but if you take a
person from an unemployed state and put
that person in an employed state the
marginal yeah you know a big fraction of
that dollar is gonna get spent and so
that's why keep doing it yeah I mean you
know we've got two and a half million
unemployed construction workers for
example you could just double down all
the existing construction projects
currently run by state federal and local
authorities and put people and and get a
lot of people to work with a multiplier
effect maybe of - so maybe get three
four million jobs out of do that and at
some point the market does begin that
worried about your your you know the
budget you've got to combine it you got
to combine it right like I said long
term with the long term for it to be
credible
ya know a feeling we were solved solving
this would will you put a value-added
tax and you've got corporate taxes
exactly you'd raise Social Security
government and to empower the Medicare
Commission so that it can make real
gossip we're percent insane
so if if we were whinge about we could
get it done right we have we have a
little problem called the US Congress
that doesn't see eye to eye with this
view um come back to education do you
really think I I'm really of two minds
about this how broken is our educational
system broadly speaking I mean we see of
course we see the cream of the crop but
I don't hear people in the good state
universities talking about the decline
of the students they're seeing III think
that I think underneath what appears to
be in the aggregate a decline of the
educational system is are actually
income disparities and and that and that
the fact that we are much less
egalitarian in our institution of income
than Europe or South Korea or Japan that
what we're that what we're seeing is
very low performance from low-income
families
rural and inner-city children and school
and really substandard schools there and
perfectly frank ly by national
international standards perfectly
acceptable schools in much of America
and so I I just think that the our
performance on these comparative tests
and so forth probably masks what's
actually more fundamental problem with
income distribution in this country well
let's begin by saying you're looking at
at Yale the cream of the cream of the
cream it's true the cream of the cream
so it's a very non represent right the
whenever people tell me that that the
data of you know are bad or that you
know the test is actually welcome I
always say yeah but thirty years ago we
used to do well on all the scores so
then we didn't mind it so much when you
start finding faults with the studies
because you're doing badly at them and
saying well the tests are wrong you know
yes all that is true so I agree with you
there is a big disparity
hopefully the Pisa tests which are the
ones that are used to compare across
nations we've done badly for since they
were introduced well the better but the
Pisa tests are not the only one right
you have percentage of college graduates
which is the most important well we was
to lead the world in percentage of
college graduates from the beginning of
the 20th century till about ten years
ago no we're now seventh or eighth I
think on the list
science and technical education you look
that but my basic point you Rick would
be I agree with you probably the top
forty percent of the schools in America
are really good maybe another 20 percent
are adequate but that still leaves
that's what yeah with thirty percent of
the I mean that's a very large part of
the pan goli agreed and if you ask
yourself what is hollowing out the
American economy it's the fact that you
have all these people who just can't be
employed you know there are right now
with a fifteen percent unemployment rate
real unemployment rate if you count the
people who stopped looking there are
five million jobs in this country job
openings that cannot be filled because
they cannot find people who have the
skills to me this is the most startling
statistic about America today there are
five million job vacancies that cannot
be filled right now and you know that
that's we will produce a third of our
schools are producing dysfunctional
people yeah you're right it drags down
the average if you were to look at
Scarsdale high you know my guess is
those guys do as well as the
Singaporeans yeah
but the other ones are still in there
you know they're all part of America it
does suggest that a policy maybe ought
to be targeted in in in those
communities with the and what would you
say the answer is because one one answer
I've heard is well the reason that the
top third of the country does well it's
because you frankly you throw a lot of
money at it I mean that those those
those schools are very generously funded
but they but the bottom third are not
actually I don't think the evidence
supports that I think there's I think
the per capita expenditures is more even
it's it comes from broke family
background you know income you know
what's the culture in the home so the
you know the where the intensive work is
needed I think is low income people one
way to help that is to employ more
people yes for starters you but how
would you react to this I was very taken
a couple of years ago Alan Blinder wrote
a piece Donna must he was the vice
chairman of the Fed on globalization and
he said you know we've all said
globalization is great free-trade is
great and it helps everybody but you
know actually doesn't help everybody
because while there's people at the top
were going to do fantastically and there
are some jobs that can't get out sourced
you know you have to you have to have
drivers and cooks and cleaners and
people who you know run gyms there were
all those things there's a huge portion
of people in Western societies in the
middle who's Joe who are in effect in an
international competition now and the
downward pressure on their wages from
the fact that you have a billion people
are around the world now participating
in that labor market is very real and
it's very profound and I don't I think
this is the great anxiety of the
American middle class that you're seeing
in the Tea Party you're seeing and I
don't think either party has a solution
to it and I don't know what I don't know
that there is a solution to it there are
a billion people doing those jobs yeah
that's right and and then the real wage
of certainly the factory worker in this
country has been flat or declining for
25-30 years and it'll now go into the
white-collar industries because you have
the same and as I was saying so that if
the Chinese bank gets the biggest IPO in
the world what happens to their wages
and you know in this you play that out
multiply it by a thousand and you see
where this is going and it's you know I
think it causes huge anxiety so we need
to innovate no yeah well we need to
innovate but can-can innovation alone
get you mass employment I don't know I
mean asked maybe not but he can get you
can get you wealth that generates
spending and that gets you some
employment you know I mean it's you know
obviously it doesn't it's it's an
important part of the puzzle where we
have aren't still have our natural
advantage I think yep
and it's and and I think that maybe we
should be focusing all our energies on
that you know these are the things we do
well you know innovation creation of new
industries allocation of capital to
those places rapidly free those up as
much as you can you know double down on
your on your on the things that work in
this society funding research at
universities funding right no no I I
have you think corporate which is
extremely important piece of that Nexus
what if you think about it you know if
you if you imagine that we're right that
the only hope here is innovation and
we're in a post-industrial economy and
we have to move up the value chain we
are now spending
not even what the Cold War average was
on R&D right we're a little bit under it
a little under hood which is 3% of GDP
right maybe we should be thinking to
ourselves well actually and today in
this kind of world we should be spending
five percentage you know that that we
need to raise the bar because that's the
only place when we were spending 3% we
still had a massive steel industry we
still had a massive you know aluminium
industry we had all these blue-collar
jobs actually the share that's declined
is the federal share it used to be about
one and a half percent of each federal
private republican now it's a 1 percent
federal a one and a half of 1.7% private
and by the way i didn't you know i don't
want to get too much in the weeds and
they and the in the public education
conversation but i actually think you're
going to see a an even further decline
in public education because if you look
at what's happening to the state
universities they're being hollowed out
and you know for a combination of budget
cuts rising medical costs things like
that if you look at California and you
say this is the place that you know all
the innovation all the ingenuity came
out of why did it come out of there
because lots of Engineers went to
California why did they go first of all
they went there for defense and
Department spending there was a Lockheed
and all those companies secondly
California had the best state education
system in the world kindergarten through
University of California Berkeley PhD
programs third it had fantastic
infrastructure from you know barks to t
really playgrounds to e highways it's
now the whole state is collapsing and
these you know all these universities
are doing awfully so I mean I worry a
lot about what happens when the state
university system in this country
continues to go down it's great for Yale
but it's terrible for the country it's
not great for you I mean well you get
better students and you know you forget
that you can poach some faculty but in
the long run it's not good no it's not
it's own laugh we have actually done
that it's the same we've we've done it
it's the same it's it's the same though
as the as the dynamic between China and
the US yeah you want a bigger pie it's a
positive sum game to have these these
various institutions thrive
um so come back you know to sort of sum
up the America seems a little threatened
on the economic front it actually we're
judging for what you said maybe is
beginning to refocus its priorities
appropriately and foreign policy moving
away from counterterrorism a little bit
more toward focusing on the big one on
relationships with the strongest
countries and and take a more mature
view I mean if you had your last five
minutes with President Obama what would
you tell him you know I do think Obama
gets this new world I think that part of
it is that he did you know he does
understand it because I mean not just
say this now is so politically charged
and you know people will you know will
run this on videotapes but he does have
roots in in Africa he has a background
you know that he he lived in East Asia
so I think it is not as foreign to him
and he does get it and I I have sensed
that from watching his actions from the
few conversations I've had he does seem
to understand we're in a different world
and he doesn't view it as a threat I
think he understands this new world the
question is as a society you know do we
understand it can we get to the point
where you know we can deal with a
problem like terrorism as one among many
of the problems we have rather than view
everything in this kind of obsessive
win-lose whim and think about it we are
down to four hundred members of al Qaeda
maybe fewer and President Obama can't
say you know the engagement Afghanistan
is over thank you we're gonna scale back
that would be regarded as appeasement as
surrender it is very difficult
everything is viewed from the prism of
appeasement surrender and things like
that so that would be politically costly
I think it would it wouldn't it would
create a firestorm of political
opposition which would pummel him as
being weak and he doesn't want to seem
weak I think that in the short term
there are congressional districts that
would swing because you decide no
certainly not no certainly not but it's
more the general mood of the
country is one where you're always
better off earning on the side of being
hawkish rather than double if you're if
you're a Democrat you need to cover that
flank that's what the military
understood with them maybe that's in
which is why they leaked it it would be
worth testing it would be worth testing
it and saying you know what let's grow
up there is no such thing as perfect
security the real challenge of terrorism
is how we respond to it there will be at
some point some attacks somewhere
because there are enough loonies in the
world and technology is widely available
and our challenge is to be resilient to
show these people that it doesn't work
you know me terrorism is an unusual
military tactic that it depends on the
response of the onlooker if you are not
terrorized it didn't work so it really
depends on how you take him and I give
the Indian government enormous credit
after the Mumbai attacks with enormous
pressure being placed on them by a
nationalist opposition party that was
saying you should go out and strike you
know there can't be the camps that where
this was all trained and there are le T
camps you know where they are it could
have been done they understood that that
would set off a chain reaction that
would probably be to the detriment of
the region of India and they didn't do
it and they said no we're going to
absorb the area we're gonna focus on
what we did wrong in terms of homeland
security type issues I don't worry when
people sometimes say you know a backpack
bombing would totally throw this country
into chaos actually that's not true this
is a 14 trillion dollar economy if some
wall somewhere in America three malls
got you know what shut down for two days
it would make no difference what I worry
about is not what happens in those malls
but what happens in Washington well of
course we would go nuts and we would all
be strip searched every time we
approached an airport we or a mall you
know it's that overreaction that III
think we need to get more mature about
survive September 11th 2001 better than
September 15th 2008 actually in what's
that venom in terms of people's
prosperity in daily lives
oh yes of course and that was the first
one and so it was the biggest shock I
mean if you look at the effect of
terrorism on economic activity so in
September 11 that takes three months for
the markets to return but by the time
you get to the London attack seven seven
market was back up to the same place
within 24 hours because people realize
altom Utley we have vast rich complex
societies and that one you know two or
three subway stations don't derail the
British economy Lele let alone the
American economy but you know I would
think we've got to get there the thing I
would spend my time with Obama talking
to him about is more this
competitiveness issue I'm a fan of the
president but I really don't think he
gets maybe because he's not been in
private business himself he doesn't get
the urgency with which we have to really
hustle in the world today and and that's
the best way to put it we really have to
hustle because everybody else is
hustling mmm would you tell him to put
some business person somewhere in his
government
I see Henry schacht I would tell him to
put Henry the former CEO of loosen'd
spectacularly successful business one
scientifically trained but he yeah I
mean I do think he needs it's not just
business I think a he needs a so there's
a perception problem where he doesn't
have an ambassador to the business
community which is a problem I think the
other part of it is you need people who
know how to do stuff you are well aware
of this because Rick is one of them are
successful managers I've ever seen a lot
of management is not coming up with
great ideas they people have good ideas
it's figuring out how to implement them
and I don't get the sense there are
enough people in the White House who
actually understand how to get stuff
done the one place where you see it
spectacularly successful is education
actually Arne Duncan has achieved more
as Secretary of Education than any
Secretary of Education in that I can
remember I mean I actually don't think
there is one and why is that because he
actually ran the Chicago school system
you know he this is not just writing a
policy paper for Brookings this is
actually going out then figuring out how
do you make this happen how do you get
on the ground what deals do you make
what compromises you make you know Lou
Gerstner likes to say strategy is
execution you know if you can't execute
it you might have the best idea in the
world it doesn't make a difference it's
irrelevant and I do think that that's
been part of the problem for this
administration but I do it since we're
close I want to say I am very much of
the view
that in September 2008 we were facing a
great depression if you look at every
economic index that I that I can you
know look at if you look at the
contraction and private borrowing if you
look at the destruction of employment
1.7 million jobs in one quarter 2.1 in
the next quarter this was all the worst
in 65 years you didn't you had literally
seen nothing like this since the Great
Depression you and the administration
managed to restore stability to the
financial system through a series of
actions you know regarding the banks
regarding the mortgage industry the car
industry and people forget that it was
so successful that of course now people
say what crisis we didn't need to do
anything if you know we wish we spent
all this money needlessly so if he gets
credit for nothing else I do think
President Obama deserves a lot of credit
for very good crisis management at a
period which is very critical and where
frankly all evidence we have is that the
other candidate would have done an
extraordinarily bad job and the only
thing you have to do is read Hank
Paulson's memoirs to read his absolute
horror at the prospect of John McCain
becoming president as a Republican
Servat of Republican so two cheers for
president final final question what how
can yell students contribute to the
solution of these problems oh gosh I
mean Yale students as you know are not
going to be the product the problem
yells yells students will do fine Yale
students will will be that part of the
American economy that is going to thrive
in a globalized world you're going to
have actually a larger you know the
larger world as your oyster and to the
extent that you can actually engage with
that world and travel and learn
languages and know more about it you
will find yourselves in a very good
position American businesses are
thriving for precisely that reason
American businesses have their problems
but they're much more and better
globalized than say German businesses
you know German business is still
dealing with the problem that all their
employees speak German which you know
doesn't sound like a big problem but if
you're trying to run an operation with
with you know factories in 25 countries
they're not all going to speak German
for you you know and you've got to
figure
what to do and you don't have a language
and as a result you haven't built a
culture of multinational management
which American companies have so you
have enormous advantages if you can
learn how to take advantage of this this
you know globalized world but I would
say to you you you know you are going to
live in a country where you have some
obligations for those of you who live in
the United States you will have
obligations to your fellow citizens and
to your country to try and make sure
that you're not that this doesn't turn
into Brazil or a caricature of Brazil in
the old days where there's this elite
that is doing fantastically living in
gated communities able to access capital
labor around the world but is in some
way engaged in a civic fashion with with
the society as a whole because otherwise
we will end up with a very strange
economy and what I worry about more than
the economy is the politics of a world
like that the politics of a world with a
collapsing middle class are not going to
be pretty that is the world of the 1930s
well thank you very much
you